[Music]
jurassic world dominion the third and
final installment in the movie series
will be released next summer the two
visually stunning predecessors naturally
set the bar high which is why we are
looking forward to new material all the
more in the past few days there have
been two new images to gaze at one was
published by empire magazine on twitter
on monday another one was released last
week on the picture of empire magazine
we can see how an atrocious raptor is
chasing the apparently fleeing own grady
played by chris pratt fittingly director
colin trevorrow spoke out in a related
interview where he makes clear the big
differences between the atrocious
raptors and the similar velociraptors
while the velociraptors assert
themselves through their aptitude as
cunning hunters the atrocious raptors
are clearly more vicious and brutal they
would simply charge at someone and hunt
them until they were dead besides
velociraptors and the trossarapters
there are also pyroraptors which will
give the human inhabitants of the planet
a hard time as mentioned before we also
provide you with a second image where it
comes from entertainment weekly here the
change of scenery is clearly visible as
we no longer see chris pratt and sunny
malta but in a snowy region this
represents the plot pretty well because
as we know many different places around
the world will be featured in the movie
since the dinosaurs have spread to all
places on earth the scene shown is also
entirely different because while in
malta he still had to fear for his life
here we see him trying to tame or calm
down a shy dinosaur after these images
we look forward even more to jurassic
world dominion which will be released on
june 10th 2022
in just under three months madrid's the
batman will be released in movie
theaters shortly before christmas there
was some news and pictures of the dceu
blockbuster reeves revealed some details
in an interview that will come as a
surprise to many fans among other things
reeves talked about the creative process
of the script which was strongly
influenced by the music of the grunge
band nirvana for him lead actor robert
pattinson also exudes the mixture of
vulnerability and power that he likewise
attributes to nirvana frontman kurt
cobain who passed away in 1994. as we
already saw in the teaser and trailer
patterns embodies a much darker version
of bruce wayne than in many other batman
films reeves wanted to distance himself
from the playboy version of bruce wayne
and instead show a broken man going
through a great tragedy in addition
there was a variety of images to be seen
on two covers of empire magazine batman
and catwoman are shown in their
respective suits but bruce wayne wears a
heavily armored suit catwoman stays true
to herself with a leather outfit
catwoman actress silly kravitz went on
to reveal that she has been watching
actual footage of cats and lions to
perfect her moves she notes that she is
of course physically inferior to batman
and thus must simply be faster and
willier than him on twitter med reeves
also released a new motion poster that
in keeping with the title question
everything did raise some questions
resourceful fans quickly set to work
trying to figure out the image because
they're indeed clues left by the riddler
hidden in the poster if you successfully
decipher it you will be taken to website
where the riddler is already waiting
have you already attempted in solving
the riddle and if so were you successful
feel free to tell us about it in the
comments the batman is scheduled for
release on march 4th 2022
it looked as though spiderman trilogy
would remain in the mcu for a long time
along tom holland and his version of
spider-man to return to rides holder
sony however even before the release of
spider-man no way home fans were caught
off guard when sony producer amy pascal
announced the prospect of not just one
but three new movies now marvel boss
kevin foggy has also commented on the
future of spider-man he revealed to the
new york times that they would prefer to
avoid another farewell drama like the
one that followed after far from home
and would rather work out the story of
spider-man together he even stated in no
uncertain terms that they were already
in the early stages of production on
spider-man 4. tom rothman who is the
sony executive in charge of the project
also emphasized once again how
beneficial the collaboration with marvel
is and that they are accordingly happy
to continue landing the friendly
neighborhood spider to the mcu for a
little longer how exactly the story of
peter parker will be further developed
will be revealed in the talks of the
coming weeks
the second season of the witcher kicked
off on netflix a few days ago and now
there's already new material on one of
the countless projects from the witcher
universe we're talking about the
spin-off series the witcher blood origin
which is planned to be released next
year the content is about the creation
of the very first witcher on the
occasion of the conjunction of the
spheres which caused the worlds of elves
humans and other creatures to mix 1 200
years before the main story in order to
stop the roaming monsters cruel
experiments were conducted on children
to create a super mutant to combat the
outside threat as we already know this
endeavor caused many children's life
since not everyone is cut out to become
a witcher netflix released a teaser that
gives us a first glimpse into the
conflicted story it is not yet clear
when exactly the witcher blood origin
will be released it is merely being said
that this series is expected to come out
next year
the last weeks were packed with new
images of james cameron's sequel avatar
2. on monday there was again an
exclusive image using empire magazine as
we already know the story of the family
of the main characters jake and theory
will play a significant role in the
upcoming sequels therefore it is all the
more fitting that we finally get images
of the couple's offspring we can see
miles aka spider who was left behind on
the planet and adopted by jk nathiri
besides miles there are also the
siblings natalyam lowak and duktieri
however they're all navy and not human
like their adopted brother there's also
believed to be some tension within the
family because while jake stands up for
spider what nathiri sees on him is
mainly the negative aspects since he is
of the same species as those who
destroyed her home and murdered her
father avatar 2 is scattered for release
in theaters on december 16 2022
2010 saw the release of kick-ass the
first of two films about the teenage
comic book van dave who wants to become
a superhero himself the movie which was
heavily hyped at the time failed to
convince every critic at first but all
in all it's a solid action movie with a
quirky story last week kick-ass creator
matthew vaughn surprisingly announced
that he was planning a kick-ass reboot
in the very near future in an interview
during the promo tour for von's new film
the kings man he confirmed that he was
planning to release a major reboot in
two years he added that it was probably
so crazy that he was not even allowed to
talk about it he spoke of the film being
beyond anything fans can imagine and
being fairly wacky and shocking quite
ambitious talk nevertheless we are
eagerly awaiting more information on the
upcoming kick-ass reboot
the big reunion of the harry potter
actress on january 1st 2021 on the
occasion of the 20th anniversary of the
sorcerer's stone is approaching in
keeping with the christmas season a few
days ago there was a new poster to
admire which shows the actress in
hogwarts great hall this is a nice
addition to the image published last
week which showed only the main actor
trio pictured here alongside daniel
radcliffe emma watson rupert grint from
left to right are the actors of fred and
george weasley draco malfoy luna
lovegood dean thomas neville longbottom
and ginny weasley we are definitely
looking forward to the reunion and are
eagerly anticipating january 1st 2022
when harry potter returned to hogwarts
will be shown on hbo max
that's it with our news for this week on
our channel we highly recommend our
latest original about the book of boba
fett fatherhood can also enjoy the new
trailer for the upcoming harry potter
return to hogwarts the whole team wishes
you a merry christmas and a happy and
healthy new year and is looking forward
to keeping you up to date with the
latest news from the world of film after
the holidays merry christmas and a happy
new year
[Music]